Yovani I'm shooting a film about
happiness and how everyone can improve
the world following the United Nations
2017 global goals for sustainable
development I want to use my skills to
help people around the world the
solution I found is to have an online
for-profit business is this a good
strategy yeah I think actually is a
pretty cool question the other thing I
sort of haven't touched on but I think
if you can have a business particular
sustainable development where your
business mission is around supporting
that that you've lived in over cause and
is your passion then obviously it's
really congruent and connected so I
think you can do that as well and then
actually business performance is enhance
so I've got tons of database and I will
publish this video you guys who put on
your website but we've got a study where
that says companies that actually have a
heart and do a lot of whatever you call
it colorful antha p or omissions
connected with supporting causes are
twenty percent more profitable and grow
our revenues revenue increase it by
revenues by twenty percent so so there's
a lot of data to say that productivity
improves revenues improved and they tend
to be better companies and also
obviously it's kind of a a nice thing to
say but it is so obvious you will
recruit better people because I think
the best people want to make a
difference as well and I think that's
very honorable thing to do as well yeah
and Giovanni I love the idea of mixing
them I think too many people think we'll
to do good I have to start a charity I
have to go into the nonprofit sector and
that's a noble pursuit and it works for
a lot of people but you can be
profitable and do good at the same time
and if you can make your business
extremely profitable and build up a team
than the amount of good you can do
amplifies right like the amount that
sage can do because they're profitable
business and they have a CEO of the
heart is insane
to what you know one person can do not
that that one person can't give back and
still contribute in their own way but I
love the idea of starting a business to
do good and to give back and not only
having to think about going to nonprofit
route